[Music]
K
okay
Ok it seems to
work This is Working fine so Thanks a
lot for the invitation and I hope to
stay in in the time because try
to speak about two topics Today about
The Use of seming constraint and
argumentation Please When two minutes
are left let me know Thank
you so I'm working in using seming
Starting since
1995 and the work that I'm speaking
about are the Us constraints Is Let's
Say a work that I made in my phd aot of
Time
AG5 and then jnm in  97 and I also will
try to give some insight about The Use
of in argumentation is Another important
topics Today is I think important
because used to give explanation to
machine Learning
results topic that Will speak about
That
So usually When when I speak People does
know a  lot about I have to explaining
They already constra ar iy
Jump detail the but I will try to
give at least some definition on
constraint solving
argument some New topics You can Take
Home
Ok so constraint solving is Let's say
hold topic People are Working On
Starting from  the and the appro was trying
to
solve graphical problem and the one was
to try
to interpret
3D 3D scene Starting from a two
Dimension graphical
and the same work in in A Different
Fashion Still in in the graphic in the
graphical team was made by B toly  some
geometrical constraint to interface but
the
Scientific constraints are made by
montanar in 74 By The Way is my
supervisor and by maw In The 80 in one
Paper is defined the frame in the other
Paper
defined Basic algor to solve this type
of problem so try to  give you what is
that perh not everyone knows so
set of variable v a Domain for one
variable in example are the color red
blue and and
Yellow Plus set of constra is the
Basic the Basic Brick the framework so a
constraint is defined in term of
primitive constraints  changing the
primitive constraints Change the age use
ins the
constraint How much powerful is
constraint
System the primitive constraints can be
Given in explicit Way so saying For inst
what are all the admissible to Each one
of the constraint so If I want to say
that the
connected connected  variable Has to have
different color I can explicitly say
that the admissible T are Red and Yellow
Red and Blue blue and red blue and
Yellow
or I can Express I can I can define the
constraint implicit way Just define some
relation so the the Element Has to
bewise different Each constraints is
defined by two functions the function with
the connection variable This is
Sometimes also called the type of the
constraint the support of the
constra for One the constra Which variable
involved for constraint Here the con Fun
to define
constraints definition function say what
are the possible assign for this
constraints in this case giving an
explicit way the possible One will
be the different R Blue R yellow and so
on so solving The problem means to Find
an assignment to all the variable satisf
all  the constraint
Sometimes There is Another Element In
The problem is called the distinguished
constraint and is introduced When we are
interested to know the assignment of only
only Subset of the variable Of The
problem in this case only we want to
know Only the assignment of X1 and  X3 so
How to solve the problem we have to Find
the assignment for variable satisfy the
constraint in this case there are two
Possible assignment
to assign for the variable
have to call the projection
operator
Ok many problem can represent this one
This is the Classic Gra coloring problem
many others Can Be represented So How to
solve problem effectively Because The
problem Space You have to explore isig
this is solving CP is NP problem so very
difficult  and many technique can be Used
that one Used a lot of Time is the
Search with Back Track so the idea is
that I try to instantiate the variable
in a specific
Order specific Order By The Way this
will be another Talk
What deciding is the Order assignment
the variable and Which Domain Element
assign one of the variable so let's say
I assign the Element to the to the
variable until we have a complete
assignment satisf the constraint if a
certain
Point an assignment cannot be Found I
have to backtrack and choose Element of
Domain  idea is that if you want to improve
the Search have to Find a way to reduce
the Search
Space things to do to do that is called
the local consistency many type of local
consistency in When two variables
involved by binary constraint is called
R consistency and this was  defined by
maw in the 0 so the idea is that looking
locally with polynom algorithm I can try
to reduce the Each One so for instance
looking this relation between x and Y I
easily can remove from the Domain of
assign Y Such that There
is a consistent assignment between x x
and Y so I can remove
methodology ruce Search
Space
most cons is also important because If
You Are Lucky You can also try to use
polynomial algor to completely
solve problem
ify way you not Find solution in can
ruce sech Space but
case for chance that in this case is
solv problem usually is  not enough You
have to use local consistency During the
Search with B track to
reduce as much as you can Okay
so satisf what to do the Motivation Here
the way is that Sometimes it is not enough
to solve a this because there Are Too
many constraint I want  to to to Find a
way to Anyway give a solution also if
some constra are not satisfied or there
are so many solution that you want to
Select someone that is better with
respect to another one so the idea is to
use the same in Order to guide  the
search for the best
solution
so is an giving some weight to the the
assignment of the constraint in this
example i Ass i assume that I give some
some cost to Each one of the assignment
when they perform the combination I have
to When perform the combination  I have
to in this case i Sum the cost and Each
One the solution have specific cost Ok
again are
Expert
because
Ty
can inad min the can Search Soler
probability exist or many others in
particular There is a mapping on the
using the good seming
map BP  to the classical One no
Good is very easy
Ok important Things We use the same with
the Plus operator ent We already say
many things about this Today in I want
the Plus operator to be because they
want to define a partial Order between
the Element in Order  to Select which one
is the Better Element of the same I say
Better In Order to make Confusion with
respect To The Order Okay so say B is
better than a if a+ B B
Ok When Us
In any case Ok so Which property Should
Be required for
csps  associative commutativity of the
combination operated because we consider
set of constraint we don't care The
Order of the
constraint absor of
Times because When adding constraints I
want to
have
solution
Element represent toal dislike of
solution Zero the
anator the Times and an Element That is
the Top the best that represent what is
a good solution Ok so I have the
absorptive seming so commuta seming say
that a+ a+ one are commutative hono and
absen the absor is needed Because of The
partial Order I want to define Us the
Plus we already  Spen about
Today
Ok
so try to give some detail noun System
is enan using not Only the constrain
Domain the variable constrain is a pair
the type of the constraint the
definition Fun but Time the definition
Fun for each assignment of the Domain
Value and the Operation combination  and
proje defined in Such way the
combination taking account the TIM
operator of the seeding and the
projection choose the best one Us the on
operator of
the we can make the the same Things
defined Us some functional way and is a
constra take a mapping from V  to d and
a And So
on
Ok The Good Things of the same Ring that
When we define this One We was able to
represent What was already defined in
the Past so using specific seeding We was
able to represent probabilistic CSP the
F CSP the classical One  many many others
Still Open the Question If you can
represent this One so if you want some play
with stuff you can
do example how to do this easily and
quickly so combining the constraints
means to take into account the combination
operator the seeding in this case for the
phas  is the minimum put Together The
Element so i perform The minimum between
09 08 and 0909 for this style we have 08
we can do the same For The Others Okay
and if you want to know the assign for X
a have to Project over a So you  have to
perform the Maximum between th three
Value That is 08 Okay so classical
definition of the classical CSP extended
to semiring the next step is to try to
define local consistency also for this
framework This is most important
Things so how to do
that local
consistency How  It work take a Subset of
the variable in case x13 for instance and try to Project
Domain of This is what is done in
the classical CSP We to do something
similar in The Soft
CSP in this case we are not to remove
the Value but we have to we are not
remove the Domain
Element redu the Value
associated the Domain Element so the
idea is that notice that Zero means the
meaning
that assignment not possible for the
variable Ok taking this two variable
Project over X3 means to perform this
Operation so performing the combination
of the two constraint with the
variable notable the unary constraints
of the variable and then perform  the
projection over
in this example I perform The
combination say the mean between all the
Value this One and have to Project Over
the variable the Value that was to the
blue col was after the project is2 so I
obtain a better approximation What will
be the real assignment at the  End of the
computation to the assignment of
will Skip
it theistic
One
the in
particular
operator
Max
is
not If I for The rule That the prev
slide IB The constra
project
Ok Value that does not satisfy the
solution does not
can
the Ide is
that
multiply I say multiply Because the
operator the any we  can instan operator
to any other other operator we can
multiply all the Element for any any
Value in cas 08 and obtain 072 on this
One and then divide for the same 08 The
Other
Element So Over
Solution How You can divide Because you
have a sowing The  Division is not
defined Ok
Well what we will do we
extend Ok how to do this We use resid
Theory with resid Theory we can
approximate the solution of the Question
B Time x is with the maximal of this sub
solution so the set of  b x
Lower a we are Sure that if Such Element
exist Element exist Such That the
Question Is equal This is the maximal
solution so When The Division can be
defined we have the Perfect solution
When we are not we have some
approximation means
that Let's say instead of  make The
Division perfectly We will have
Something not So Good approximation we
can do something
Division by Res in the seed
so Division so the opposite Times in the
classical CSP Just implication for the
for the Weed Are
Just One B is Lower than a Just a if  a
Is Lower than B for thep Just in thep we
have the Plus operator Just minimum only
When you perform you can perform the
minimum in so When a Is greater than B
so When only when you can perform the
subt This is a good idea This is  the
idea that We use to extend the local
consists to also
not Good
How Try also to give some detail on How
to extend this time not but
argumentation
to
withering So What is argumentation
argumentation
is a framework where we represent
argument that Each one that can be  Used
When you When we have a discussion a
debate among user in this example we to
us that say some argument
debating so he say something Attack the
argument of the Guys And So on So we
have situation like this One in this
case What argumentation do usually  want to to
Find Out Which are the argument
Stay Well together so Who Survive there
to President candidate pres make a
debate you want to at the End of the
debate understand Who say the good
Things have to find arum
adding here means that you want to give
a one of the Attacks some Attacks may be
Stronger than another one so if in the
classical case
a defend Itself from the Attack to be if
Give weight Could Be that defend Could
Be enough more
formally argumentation
FR Gra Time connection between the No
are Direct Edge  Because the Direction of
the Attack and is defined by the set of
argument the
Node a relation
represen The conflict the Attack So we
say that an Attack in B There is a Direct
from a to B with this framework we have
to Find I say the argument  together so
the more
easy conflicte so in example a Stay Well
together because every single Stay Well
together but for AB cannot Stay Together
because There is an Attack AC can Stay
Together CD cannot say And So
on another step is not to Find Only the
conflict set  but to Find the argument
that are able to defend by the other so
for instance AC is able to defend the
because it is attacked by D but
the same BD for instance can not stay
together because D is attacked by C but
defend Itself B is attacked by  a by C
the attacking from C is defended by His
friend D but the Attack Coming from a is
not defended so BD is not an extension
That is
admissible many semantic defed we don't
about that
many
I use Here the the weing where the
weight  is compared with the other
respect the minimum and If There are two
guys saying That is Sunshine
Rain Stronger the
Attack Strong minute
more
so instead of Just having argument and
relation also aing and a weight
funing Element to the
attacking We about
that we can define the  Defense function
Just considering the weight of the ATT
for inst
defend
the
is the admissible extension Ok we have
to put Together we have to combine the
way together so for instance the ATT
Day from a to b s is defeated by the
Defense of DS together when you  say
together means use the combination
of and again the ATT Go from F to this
set let say to d and and a That is 5 +
38 is not defeated by the set because D
Sorry the Attack from D to F and from C
to F is  5+ 27 Okay so i combine The both
the weight of the Attack and the weight
of the Defense This Is A Different
approach for from What already defined
by other other other proposal Where They
does not
combination operate
Andy going to the the
end having the weight  we can give a
relax definition conflict free
allowing some Attack Inside the set
Okay so this One Could Be not conflict
free but have relaxation of Two
unit conflict we have relaxation from
outside
There is an Attack of Five defend two if
if adit of unit be enough  Ok two minutes
so i
Finish
Time If we want to play with this One We
implemented argumentation framework as a
tool using CSP By the way to put this
together And you can find it
Here the reference of Talk on the slide
book with many details about using  low
constraint
and many Open problem Question that we
can discuss on this later on i Thanks
for the
Attention we have Time For
question
Den any any variations of this frw that
effent to calc
and soft Logic relaxation of normal
Logic She also needs to use
some
Logic  One particular Sem there some You
can for one Things that we can say that
if the
time easier to perform local consist is
do because trying to study complexity
with respect to the respect to the
specific be topic
to Stud because ching operator
Change
comp Good so then  I think Let's Thank
the speaker once again Thank
you so Now we have a Coffee Break and